my man so uh how are you how you doing
there man get the scene
[Music]
welcome home this is your home we're
happy to have you as many times you know
we can yeah man I'm here like every
other weekend whoever thought I could
have a residency in Vegas one thing that
we always look for when we look at
artists that are gonna be residents and
we want them to call this place homes
it's the people that gonna come and give
a show not just get on stage do five
songs get off but do a full show give
the people what they want to see here
Dre's are able to see you as an intimate
one-on-one and that's something that you
can only see here in Vegas here we have
tables that range anywhere from five
thousand to a hundred thousand dollars
it can be crazy you know you have a
hundred thousand dollar two hundred
thousand dollar table which is where
you're sitting right now this right here
is the hundred thousand dollar section
it's whole section gonna grip you got a
group of 20 people come and have the
best time in your life is right here so
you have to understand sitting right
here
you have the best show the best view of
the show that you could ever have this
is always booked bro
always this is not this is never empty
bro people come a lot of people come one
time of year two times you they're not
coming and that's kind of what they said
it's always a different so they're
saving up they're like you know what I
want to come in two months three months
from now and I want the best table I
don't care what it costs I want the best
table Wow
so what comes with the hundred thousand
dollars in the six thirty forty fifty
bottles it can be a giant Dom rail of 20
bottles of Dom Perignon you can get
cases of ice that basically look like
faces of it looks like gold is hidden in
the face like oh my god freezin so you
know you have all these different
packages you can get and the
presentations of what we do is we make
you feel like a rock star we make you
feel like you are the only person in the
club what we're gonna show you tonight
and first time ever we're trying this is
called the beforever
I haven't even tried it it's called the
billionaire sangria basically what
you're gonna see it's a mixture of
rose' which can be aged up to 20 years
okay you have Hennessy XO which almost
has 30 years of odevened and then
basically you have diamond ice cubes
that are gonna have the Dre's insignia
in the ice cube and to top it all off
you're gonna have some 24 karat gold
leaf yeah they get this big in this area
what would that cost that specifically
is gonna cost them about $2,500 so
basically we're gonna kill it in front
of us right now we're going we're going
we're gonna chef it up yes sir
and you just got a $2,500 punch bowl
mm-hmm but didn't get you lids yeah you
just can't find it anywhere else on this
trip the the fruits we hand-cut before
every night for the one person we may
not sell one but the one person that may
buy it we want to sell it just goes out
the window like that and so we're gonna
make sure everybody here get some okay I
don't want anybody to be shot because
you're working you behind the camera
will get you live let's go
[Music]
so this is how we make you feel like a
rockstar music they use it got used to
have news it with y'all brain that I
don't put all you know how to poke you
see people don't know that that bottom
is for your Tom you know that is all
about
it's pretty good that'll be good night
Oh a lot of gold in there floating
around go come out just like it go in No
so what do you think [ __ ] go poop
yeah I think it's a matching lint and I
think I'm sitting on a gold mine
all right get glad this year the
strongest [ __ ] now what y'all doing with
this fruit is it fresh let's do it as a
rumor turn
it's a lychee what's this little star I
want inside it bruising there it's my
new thing
hey I'm making up one inside approves oh
sit there's his throne